And now, for you, Scoutmaster.
So these two bear biologists are headed off into the woods.
Wait a minute.
They're not bear biologists.
They're wearing clothing, but they're studying bears.
You got it?
Yeah.
So they're headed way off into the backcountry to do a field study on some bears,
put on their backpacks, hike in.
They get about five miles in, and they get to a trail sign,
and the sign says, Bear Left.
So they said, well, what the heck?
We might as well go home.
Hey, it's podcast number 33.
Hey!
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
In our 33rd podcast, we're going to begin with Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
We're going to talk a little bit about den chiefs,
and featuring an interview I did with one of the scouts in our troop who's a den chief.
Then the return of this has got to be true because nobody could make this up,
a story from summer camp.
And we're going to finish with answering a couple of emails.
That's a lot to do.
Let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
So school goes back in session, and scouting gets ready to begin again.
Troops and packs are beginning to meet, and they're starting to sort things out,
and they've settled their schedule, and they're ready to be active again.
Let me ask you this.
How many den chiefs are part of your troop leadership?
Den chiefs.
Now, you should be familiar with the role of den chief.
This is a scout who's going to go and assist a Cub Scout den.
And this can be a den of any description.
It can be all the way from Tiger Cubs through Weeblos 2.
A den chief is a wonderful job for a scout.
It's a great thing for them to do.
It's a school of leadership for them.
It really can be a very big confidence builder.
And it really, it not only does that, but it assists the Cubs and the den leader.
And it also helps to cement a relationship with those Cubs when it's time for them to choose a troop
to graduate into after Weeblos 2.
So, den chiefs are a very important aspect of scouting,
and it needs to be guys who know what they're about
and who are able to really bring something to the table as a den chief.
We've always used the position of den chief as kind of an entry-level leadership position
because we know it's going to be supervised pretty closely by an adult,
that it's going to be working with Cubs who are,
well, I know they're all over the map behavior-wise,
but usually they show a great deal of deference and respect to an older scout.
And it works very well.
Now, I had the opportunity earlier this year to sit down and talk with one of my scouts
who works as a den chief and just asked him a few questions about it,
and I thought it might be interesting for you.
The job is what I thought it was going to be.
It was going to be helping out with the running of a Cub Scout den,
and that's exactly what it is.
I come, I help out with whatever they need me to do.
And a positive experience for you?
Yeah, because I get to, I mean, I get to go back to Cub Scouts,
which is kind of like a neat time.
And also, I get to help out.
I mean, that's always a good feeling, you know?
Yeah.
Has it been aggravating enough?
I wouldn't say so.
No, not at all.
It hasn't really infringed on my schedule in any way.
What would be, like, the optimum age, in your humble opinion, age for a dent chief?
The optimum age?
14 or 15.
You think that's the youngest you would go?
That's, no, I think that's about, like, the center, the median age, I guess,
for somebody who would be doing this.
So you would go a little bit younger?
Sure.
I would be, I would think that somebody who is 13 could easily do this.
Okay.
What would be the two or three things you would tell somebody who is going to be a dent chief?
Well, first they have to be good with, like, you know, little kids and not get completely annoyed.
Or, like, you know, go, like, completely around the bend when they have to come in contact with them for an extended period of time.
But, I mean, other than that, it's not, it's certainly not a difficult job.
It's, um, it's a responsibility, but it's not something that's going to, like, completely throw a wrench into your schedule.
Well, that should give you a pretty good idea of a few reflections from a scout who has served as a dent chief and the kind of things he experienced.
This particular scout went on to become a senior patrol leader.
He had served as a patrol leader prior to his dent chief experience, which sounds a little backwards,
because usually you would think, like I said earlier, a dent chief is kind of an entry-level leadership position,
and then that moves on into patrol leader and then one of the other more senior leadership positions in the troop.
I had this wild idea, thinking that my 15-, 16-year-old scouts, who had done a lot of leadership and things like that
and didn't have as active a role in the, you know, senior leadership of the troop, might be interested.
We offered them the idea of going and helping out with Cub Scout dens, and several of them caught on and really enjoyed themselves.
They went back having, you know, a little more maturity and a little more knowledge, and they were really able to help out,
and the den leaders really appreciated it as well.
So there you go.
There's just a quick little reflection on what dent chiefs are and what they do,
and an encouragement to you to get a good dent chief program running in your troop as soon as you can.
This has to be the truth, folks, because there is no way anyone could make this up.
So finally, finally, the Sunday that we head off for our week at summer camp rolls around.
And I've got all my stuff, and the scouts are on their way, and we head on down.
We get moved into our campsite, and we're getting settled, and parents have dropped the scouts off.
Myself and two other adult leaders are there with about 24, 25 boys.
You know, 24, 25.
Who counts, right?
I mean, they move around so much.
When can you ever count them?
But anyway, we're down there, and, you know, as the guys are getting ready to head out for the health check
and the swim test and things like that, my cell phone rings.
You heard me.
My cell phone rings right in the campsite.
Yeah.
I guess they put a new tower up somewhere.
Now, we're in a reasonably built-up area.
Here in the mid-Atlantic states, you know, there's not too many places I guess you can go without your cell phone ringing.
Ugh.
So anyway, I answer the cell phone, and I get a message from one of the parents who's just dropped one of the boys off that there's a big thunderstorm heading our way.
And, yeah, you know, the thunderstorm comes and passes through a little later on that afternoon.
And then we've been off to retreat and dinner and to a big campfire, and we're sitting around our picnic table in the evening.
And the boys are headed off to bed.
Taps is about to blow soon.
One of the guys that's with me, one of the adults that's down there with me, assistant scoutmaster, says, you know, I think I'll give my wife a call.
And I said, oh, yeah, fine.
So he takes a step or two away from the picnic table, gets the phone, dials his home number.
And we only heard one side of the conversation, obviously.
He said, yeah, hi, we're here.
Oh, yes, he's doing fine.
Yeah, I'm fine.
No, the storm didn't hit us too bad or anything like that.
And then he says,
then he says,
yeah, honey, it's amazing.
The cell phones work right here in the campsite.
And just as he gets the last part of the word campsite out of his mouth, his face falls and a look of horror spreads across his face.
And he looks at the two of us sitting at the picnic table.
And of course, we too are horrified.
And those words are words that we could never get back.
So we just had to turn the cell phones off for the rest of the week.
Oh, what a pity.
What a shame.
Yeah, honey, the cell phones work right here in the campsite.
Oh, I'll never forget that look.
Yeah, true story.
He's my favorite all time boy scout.
You're my favorite all time boy scout.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
Yeah, you were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'm hanging in the street, boy, street boy.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
Yeah, you're my favorite all time boy scout.
You're my favorite all time boy scout.
He's my favorite all time boy scout.
Write me a letter.
Send it by name.
Email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Here's an email I received from Scoutmaster Mike in Kentucky.
He says, I've really been appreciating your podcast.
I'm a new Scoutmaster and have an important question.
Our troops' older Scouts are down quite a bit in numbers,
and that means we have a whole bunch of new Scouts
and just a few older Scouts.
With this, our patrol method utilization has been lacking.
So what's the number one thing, in your opinion,
you can do to jumpstart the patrol method?
Well, Mike, I actually get this question quite a bit.
People listen to the podcast,
or they just kind of observe what's going on within the troop,
and they say, yeah, you know,
we don't really have much of a patrol method going.
You know, my answer to those questions usually are
just start using patrols.
It's, honestly, it's really kind of that simple.
Don't worry about the boys.
They will get it.
They will get it very quickly.
You know, just get to the next troop meeting
and have the guys divide themselves into patrols,
have them elect a patrol leader,
have them elect a senior patrol leader,
and let them at it.
That's really what it takes.
Boys understand this intuitively.
They form groups and gangs and cliques
and things like that all the time.
So they understand exactly what a patrol is.
They might not call it a patrol outside of scouting,
but they understand exactly what it is.
They understand being a member of a team.
They understand leadership.
They understand how to do things.
Now, you'll need to train your leaders,
but that training doesn't need to be, you know,
three weekends, taking them away
and showing them a lot to PowerPoint slides.
They can be trained in five-minute increments
just before it's time for them to lead.
It really is, really is kind of that simple.
If scouts haven't been a part of a real patrol,
they'll have some things to learn,
but they learn so very quickly.
Once you have patrol leaders leading,
you'll have to keep the adults out of the way
and let the boys take care of things,
let them do things.
Now, it will take some time
to make things happen
to where they're really going
and really moving on and things like that,
but the group of scouts that starts up
in this type of way
who form patrols and elect their leadership
and everything like that,
they're going to be very energized
and very excited about the process.
A lot of times, the biggest obstacle
of making the patrol system happen
is our impatience and reluctance and fear as adults,
and those obstacles really don't go away.
We just learn how to ignore them.
So that's my advice to anybody
who is in this kind of patrol system conundrum.
Just get it rolling.
The boys know how to take care of it.
They know real well,
and you'll be surprised how good they are at it.
Here's another email
that I received
with another pretty common question, actually,
and this email comes to me
from Jerry in Texas.
Here's what Jerry had to say.
He says,
First, let me thank you
for the many hours of work
that you put into the podcast.
Your candor, wisdom, and humor
is remarkable
and as a scoutmaster, very relevant.
Well, thanks, Jerry.
It's always good to hear good things.
I'm glad you find the podcast useful.
I do have a question like your input.
In the past,
we have allowed scouts
to use some requirements
earned in merit badges
to suffice
as proficiency
for rank,
and he gives the example
of swimming.
I don't think there's a problem
that the scout
has demonstrated
proficiency in swimming
in order to earn
the merit badge
to make sure
that he gets it,
you know,
that that
can be applied
to the rank requirement
for swimming.
It's a new twist occurred
when a scout asked my permission
to earn service hours
for STAR.
I approved it.
He completed the task,
but unbeknownst to me,
he had also asked
his merit badge counselor
for citizenship service hours
referring to the same task.
So,
is that right?
Or is that wrong?
Is it okay
to use the swimming requirement
earned in a merit badge
to apply for a rank?
Is it okay
to use the service requirement
for STAR
to apply to
can that same work
go ahead and apply
in the merit badge situation?
Well,
these kind of questions
really do come up
all the time,
especially around
camping merit badge,
and I'm not even
going to touch that.
I'm not even going to touch that
in this podcast,
but
I'll tell you what
solves the problem.
Most of the time,
99% of the time,
what solves the problem
is reading the requirements
and reading them carefully.
So,
let's take the example
of the citizenship
in the community requirement,
the service part of it,
and it's requirement number seven.
It says,
do the following,
choose a charitable organization
outside of scouting
that interests you
and brings people
in your community together
or work for the good
of your community.
And then,
it says,
with your counselors
and your parents' approval,
contact the organization
and find out
what young people
can do to help.
While working on this merit badge,
volunteer at least
eight hours of your time
for the organization.
After you volunteer
and your volunteer experience
is over,
discuss what you've learned
with your counselor.
So,
that's the requirement there.
Now,
let's read the star requirement
for service,
which is requirement number four.
While a first class scout,
take part in any service projects
in,
I'm sorry.
While a first class scout,
take part in service projects
totaling at least
six hours of work.
These projects must be approved
by your scout master.
And that's it.
Now,
what we have to do
is ask ourselves
if the scout fulfilled
both of these requirements.
Now,
the merit badge requirement
is really much more specific
than the rank requirement.
The merit badge requirement
says that
the organization
should be outside of scouting.
It needs to work
for the good of the community.
The scout has to learn
about the organization.
He has to get approval
from his parents
and his counselor
to contact him.
He then has to get approval
for the work
that he's going to do.
He needs to volunteer
to do that work
in a minimum of eight hours.
And then he needs
to discuss what he learned.
The star requirement
is really very general
by comparison.
And,
you know what?
When I sat and read this
to answer this email,
I learned something new.
And I'll tell you
about that in a second.
It doesn't really have
any broad specifics
about the project.
It just says
the scoutmaster
needs to approve of it.
So,
there's no specific
or implied limitation
in the application
of the work
a scout did
for the merit badge.
It doesn't say,
yeah,
you do this project
but you can't apply it
to any ranks or anything.
And it doesn't say
in the rank requirement,
doesn't specifically
prohibit him
from applying it
to the rank requirement.
And I really don't
have a problem.
Actually,
you've got to pat
the scout on the back
for noticing this
and for using
his time really well.
Now,
naturally,
we want to have
more service than less.
And we don't want
boys just kind of like
playing this game
where,
you know,
they drop a quarter
in the machine
and they get a gumball out.
We don't want
advancement to be that.
We want it to be
a recognition of
like real motivations.
But in this instance,
this doesn't look like
double dipping to me.
It looks perfectly acceptable.
Now,
what did I learn
in reading that
scout requirement
for STAR?
It doesn't say anything
about the fact that
for that service work
for STAR
that the organization
has to be outside
of scouting.
Go ahead.
Open the book.
Read it.
It doesn't say that.
Which really surprised me
because that's been
one of my general
understandings all along.
You know,
Eagle projects
can't be done
inside of scouting.
And so I just kind of
extrapolated that
out to the STAR
and LIFE service time
but apparently I'm wrong.
So now I know.
Now I've learned something.
And I almost always do
when you take a question
like this,
you go back
to the requirements
and you actually read them.
And you look at them
carefully
with a fair amount
of equanimity
and without judgment.
And then you develop
a logical conclusion
based on what you read.
It can be very revealing.
So I know that
you might feel differently
and your argument
might have some merit.
Like I said,
of course we want
more service
rather than less.
We want scouts
to do more things
rather than less.
But if we don't find
any verbiage
to support the way
that we feel,
you know,
and the argument
that we have
must be just plain wrong.
I mean,
I just learned something new
by reading that requirement
carefully.
I used to tell scouts
that their service projects
for rank
had to be something
outside of scouting
but that doesn't seem
to be the case.
So live and learn.
Now,
this is a common question.
This comes up
all the time.
I've seen it
asked many times.
People have asked it
of me a number of times
about double dipping
on these requirements
and things like that.
And you would think
if there was a quick,
easy answer
or if there was
a policy statement
behind it
that you would find it
because
this is a
very,
very common question.
And there is no
language that I can find
in the Advancement Committee
Guidebook
or in any other
national publication
that tells us
exactly how to handle
these situations
because
all we have to do
is read the requirement.
And once we've read
the requirement carefully
and we've kind of
worked it out
in our heads,
the answer is right there.
So there's the emails
for this week.
Thanks very much.
And you can email me
at ClarkGreen,
C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
at gmail.com.
Thank you for listening
to this,
the 33rd
installment
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmaster.typepad.com
and follow us
at Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook
and Scoutmaster CG
on Twitter.
You can subscribe
to the Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes
and when you do,
feel free to leave
a comment
or a review
or a rating.
And as I just said
a moment ago,
you can email me,
Clark Green,
with your comments
and questions
at ClarkGreen
at gmail.com.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America.
No,
no,
not at all.
It's just me
talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand
to Scout leaders
and perhaps have a bit
of fun along the way.
As always,
before we go,
we'd like to hear
from our founder.
Sir Robert,
what have you to tell
everyone this time?
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why,
thank you,
Sir Robert.
Until next time,
everyone.
Erin King,
why,
Archie Safari,
thank you,
thank you.
Thank you.